all right we got a bunch more things to
talk about project Morpheus it was
called before it's been renamed sony vr
on today we got a bunch more information
about games for it but not necessarily
the big crazy reveal of date or price
we're looking forward to Peter your RV
or person du jour what do you think
about what so you snowed off today I
think they're taking some smart moves
when it comes with the initial offerings
because kind of beating a dead horse
here but games you make for VR are best
when they're made for of you are from
the start and law that has to do is sort
of mimicking the real world in the game
so you're sitting in a chair and it's
the same as sitting in a cockpit or
sitting in a car so to have granturismo
sport announced for VR makes a lot of
sense they showed that other game which
was sort of like a you were those like
those suits and was like a sport Riggs
Riggs yeah yeah yeah oh yeah eSport you
[ __ ] but you know then they showed off
stuff like you Valkyrie again it's in a
short little trailer that one looks so I
came looks so promising and I've played
it loved it and I think a lot yeah there
we go so like a lot of these little
experiences are going to be really good
they also showed off the bottles own
battle zone which is a it's taking like
an old like vector based pc game and
bringing that which was kind of nice for
me because i used to play that a lot as
a kid Robert yeah sure Robinson the
journey which is a kind of looked like
destiny with that little character
flitting around the portal portal or
portal for yeah I guess you're right
yeah yeah um when we also got until dawn
and second and my kids seconds a weird
one I'm really curious how Tekken is
gonna work in pretoria oh yeah what if
they did like a first-person fighting
them be yeah and you put on a vest until
you have to furlough to get a punch let
me be too optimistic but I mean I think
that will be an interesting experiment
and it's a safe experiment because you
know it's uh it's so clearly a gimmick
that they're not trying to say oh this
is this grand new VR experience it's
like this it's check-in do you want to
try it in VR where's my wonder what
Crytek are doing yeah presumably they
want to you know that their engine
salesman at this stage more than
anything else so presumably they want to
be able to show off that hey also our
engine can do your stuff in at the box
yeah they've been working I believe
within video for a while to have the
hardware work with their engine really
well but back in you three I try to demo
where you are sort of scaling a cliff
and you crane your neck up as you would
when you're climbing a cliff and
eventually if Slyke look down cuz things
fall and I believe I was going to like
get eggs from a dinosaur model or
something like that it was a fine little
demo I'm curious to see what this whole
experience is going to be like how big
they're gonna make it because these
experiences especially when it's trying
to be immersive have to be so everything
has to be considered for and taken into
account in terms of the environment the
atmosphere to make a full game that does
all those little things to make it work
well in VR it's going to be expensive so
maybe Robinson will just be sort of like
a small demo that will prove to other
companies use our tech but it's not
going to be the problem if we keep
getting these small demos like until
dawn rush of blood like I get why
they're dipping back because I guess
that name has the surprising amount of
cash a actually at this stage people who
was well received but it's not kind of a
problem like we're still talking about
these little side project game i don'ts
not a problem at all vr is is so young I
mean look like look back to it you know
any game console in the 70s and 80s and
look at those tiny games and say isn't
it a problem that we only have you know
pong isn't this where is the bigger you
know I this tech will mature over time
people's efficiency to develop for VR
will improve over time so we're the
early stage I don't think this is a
problem they need to get small things in
consumers hands because people will not
be ready to do a 50-hour game right if
you right away the bat only not a
five-hour game like I want an experience
that I can sit and I can expire tea and
then maybe share with a friend and
that's the other thing that's important
is like the art us talking about it and
just like seeing videos of it doesn't
sell it you have to try it and if you
have an experience is like oh yeah I got
in for the first five minutes of this
game I'm not sure how much it's gonna
how much better it's gonna be whereas
here's a self-contained five-minute
experience like yeah it's perfect yeah
like the Danny's demo at Gamescom when
we did the oculus touch oh yeah
completely the thing I mean just
watching your reactions in that it was
like see like before I didn't know how
excited you were when you're in it was
like no question he's loving this right
now and that's just too said like things
like the Walker here this is a great
weight way to get people
wouldn't play games as well to have an
experience with VR and understand its
power yeah I mean at least maybe that
games in the traditional sense we're
going to think of complex hardcore games
but interactive media where you are you
know putting yourself into the
experience in one way or another Mike do
you do you think you would rather do
this or be put in a virtual reality pit
of snakes oh my god neither Heights and
snakes not have choices right the the
heights I am terrified of heights but
snakes are worse uh but yeah that that
is an experience I probably want to try
I don't know how long it lasts before I
yeah my legs start shaking
uncontrollably I get secondhand fear of
heights too just seeing someone else oh
wait yeah yeah it's a little like the
balconies at like really big theaters I
can't see someone so next the edge when
I grabbed him hold on to him please have
a big 90 inch projection screen and I
played assassin's creed one and my dad
walked up side and when nope okay Justin
final point on the ortho do you think if
we didn't see a release date on the
price today and we're gonna see the
PlayStation experience or maybe we'll
2016 I we're seeing so many games and
that means that they're gonna be there
close to market like they're showing an
experience that you're gonna be able to
purchase soon so we have to have in a
release date in a price and I think
we're gonna hear that a place to
experience a PlayStation experience I
think one of the reasons that are
holding off it's gonna be really [ __ ]
expensive yeah an oculus they've already
said like no we're not gonna be able to
hit that same dev kit price point when
you look at the hollow lens which is you
know very different experience a very
self-contained thing that's several
thousand or close to ten thousand
dollars Collins is also way off that I
mean the price that they're quoting for
that now is not anything that we should
consider but Sony's other VR experience
of like their other wraparound headset
that's over a thousand dollars that was
free market that misunderstood where
technology is right now that was for I'm
a rich person I'm gonna buy a 1200 ollar
headset great lets me see a 70 inch
screen that's like their lie and
television kind of stuff yeah it's got
that Sony is is that's a whole different
section of Sony that made that it's just
luxury [ __ ] this is the luxury
bullsh yeah this is like this is going
to be you know they're targeting
mass-market stuff with this so you're
getting mass market but they have said
that this is basically a standalone
console this is its own standalone
expiry
I mean not in the sense that you can
only buy this you'll still need a
Playstation 4 but that they're not going
to target this as like here's a
fifty-dollar accessory this is of course
no but but but the hardware could be
subsidized by the game sales right the
same way that they sold PlayStation 3 at
a loss to begin with wasn't a great idea
but that was down to manufacturing
issues which complicated the whole
scenario here if they can say look we
have an install base we're going to be
releasing games for it people seem to be
liking it they're going to be okay
taking a bit of a law so they can recoup
that money the software it's good i
think they're going to do that yeah just
got me just to see what price point then
on that because it's been nine years
since e3 2006 i'm talking about but yeah
let us know what you think of sony vaio
at what they showed off at paris games
week and what price point you'd be
willing to stretch to to get in on the
vo revolution let us know in the comment
box below